she'll be talking about uh collaborate
to innovate about lab of the future and
women and stuff
to introduce anchor she has more than 10
years of international management
experience
creating and leading
in cross-functional team working with
large corporates and smes she has led
the introduction of new products and
services across 140 markets in her
current role as a consultant at the
pastra alliance she is a strategic theme
lead for improving the efficiency and
effectiveness of rnd her role includes
leading communities of interest in life
science and health r d for more than one
three member companies including the
pistol alliance lab of the future
community she also leads the pistol
alliance's new women's assembly
leadership pilot program and is
responsible for developing other
non-competitive cross-industry
initiatives where members of the vista
alliance can collaborate to solve common
challenges together
so pleased to have you with us mrs anka
are you here
i
can't can you hear me
yes yes i can hear you
thank you very much for the introduction
thank you very much also for the
invitation could you see my screen can
you see my screen yes
we can see a screen
so um
again thank you for the invitation i'm
really happy here
my name is anka and before i start this
presentation
i would really want to tell you some
some things about me about my
educational background and career
background
i studied biotechnical engineering i
have a master's degree in the medical
engineering from the polytechnic
university
of bucharest and an mba degree from the
vu executive academy in vienna i must
confess that
although the university helped me a lot
in forming my mindset and in developing
the logical approach when it comes to
solving different problems
i never worked in the area i thought
that i'm preparing for as an engineer
what i did after graduation i actively
searched to join a multinational company
from the pharma industry because i had
the desire of
having a job that for me was meaningful
in terms of helping the people in need
but in the in the same time i had the
dream of of uh
becoming the type of the
business person that travels from places
to places and meets different people and
cultures so i wanted this international
exposure and i really wanted to meet and
work with with people from different
cultures
so uh i climbed in my career uh from a
project management and marketing uh
starting with romania
then i moved to responsibilities on
central eastern europe and then i went
at the european level uh
responsibility in in
less than seven years within the same
company
then i moved to a small medium
enterprise for a number another number
of years
where i got global responsibilities and
where i built the project management
department and then i became an
independent consultant
i joined the pistol alliance as a
strategic film lead as he presented
earlier and in my current role i see
myself as a connector
i connect people i connect their ideas
for
more than 200 member companies of the
pistol alliance all across the r and the
ecosystem
i facilitate collaborations between
these companies in order to address and
to solve common challenges in a
non-competitive way
in this session i'm going to present two
of the currently running initiatives one
is called the lab of the future which is
a community of interest
and the other one is the women in stem
which is a program that we are currently
piloting
do you see my next slide
yes we can see that you see the next
slide okay thank you very much
so uh uh before going into the
presentation i'd like to tell you a few
words about the pistol alliance for
those of you that maybe didn't have the
chance to work with this organization
it's a not-for-profit organization
uh it gathers under its umbrella more
than uh 200 member companies including
the 16 out of the 20 pharma companies
uh top 20 pharma companies and the
mission is to lower the barriers to
innovation in life science
and in health care and r d through
pre-competitive collaboration
this means that we bring at the same
table different companies that might be
competitors in the business environment
but we facilitated collaboration between
them for a common purpose
the covet 19 changed our lives in many
many ways including in the way we work
more companies became more permissive to
remote working
and the cross industry collaborations
also increased we saw high acceleration
of digital transformations across the
healthcare industry
and the benefits of this
industry-wise collaborations are very
well known and
more and more organizations we see that
are leveraging a legal framework that
not-for-profit organizations can
facilitate in order to collaborate with
the different organizations
research-based organizations maybe
digital technology players also page
patient groups for example
uh both of the examples that i'm going
to show you are global initiatives which
means that we involve people around the
world to support each other to share and
to learn and to address certain
challenges but also to look for
solutions together in the benefit of the
whole industry
and
when you will go on the pistol alliance
website you can see a list of projects
and the list of communities of interest
and i highlighted just some of them on
the right side of the screen
uh among all these initiatives we also
have the lab of the future community
which has a mission of driving a
pre-competitive approach to building the
next generation of laboratory
environment and we are looking from a
perspective of data standards processes
instruments and knowledge sharing
and the members of this community are
presenting use cases are sharing the
challenges and best practices but they
are also exploring different ideas and
initiate projects that can help support
the lab transformation in the
digitization
pathways
now one of my roles here
is to further more develop this
community and the engagement between the
participants so we are looking at short
medium long term perspectives and we
organize dedicated workshops webinars
projects and community discussions
looking at the improvements that can be
done in supporting these lab
transformations
no matter how far an organization is in
this
process in the digital journey
so we gather the good mix of industry
experts from the pharma cross tech
supplies academia also and other types
of organizations with wide diversity of
of roles
that are working in the ecosystem of r d
labs on the right side you see a
highlight from from the second half of
the year
when we organized uh different webinars
almost half of the participants came
from pharma companies but we also had
other organizations joining and also
almost half of the participants are
having leadership roles which means that
they are decision makers and and they
can have an influence also within the
organization but also for the
industry-wise project that we want to
develop for example
now how how will the lab of the future
look like and what does it really mean
um
there are many general predictions uh
people are talking about having a smart
lab or an automated and fully remote ai
powered
lab
cloud labs working hand in hand with
scientists
scientists working completely remotely
without
being confined within the four walls of
a lab and so on
uh but there are different types of labs
and there isn't one path that can fit
all and it's very interesting to see how
these laboratories are evolving what is
their digitalization speed their
particular vision on how their future
will look like
and
even though there are some differences
we can all agree that there are a lot of
common mechanisms
interfaces
terminology technology and so on and
they do have some similar milestones and
objectives that they want to achieve
in this transformational journey
show you
uh one of the common visions for all
type of labs is that they will make use
of the automation and digitalization so
the digital infrastructure needs to take
into account the large volume and
variety of data that is being produced
some later on challenges can be avoided
if the organizations have data
centricity in mind when implementing the
new systems and workflows and
automations
and one of the general challenges that
all
labs are facing
is how to capture this large amount of
data that is being produced
including the contextual data
in a fair format which means to be
findable to be accessible to be
interoperable and reusable
and how to redesign the current
paper-based workflow in case the
organization is still recording the
experiments let's say on on paper and
not on some electronic system
in order to fit the purpose right
how to extract the data from obsolete
device
as an example of industry initiative to
enable a fair aligned and comprehensive
semantic capture and translation of data
is the seed project that you can see on
the right side of the screen
seed comes from semantic enrichment of
eln data and eln is the electronic lab
notebook
um
this project developed a new standard
essay ontology in the phase one and now
aims at filling important ontology gaps
uh of interest for elns that are not
currently covered in the well-formed
public ontologies
another challenge related with the
digitalization is how to standardize the
practices across the industry in a way
that the data can be properly captured
and to be able to automate
somebody
something sorry you need to describe the
process
and there is a huge gap in the data
standards in the automation area and in
q3 in quarter free last year we asked
the community to highlight some of their
biggest barriers in the digitalization
process and we identified as
2 barriers
the fact that
the equipment is unable to communicate
with one another
and that there are no common data
formats so the participants proposed as
next step to create some sessions uh on
the different industry standards and
their practical
applications uh and this is what we did
we created a series of webinars where we
discussed about the adoption of open
standards and why multiple standards are
necessary conditions for digitalization
uh we then saw the need of mapping all
the process communication and data
standards that are being used by the lab
of the future community
in an easy to understand format
so now what you see on the right side
the standards mapping across the r d
value chain this is a current initiative
and we are gathering ideas on how this
mapping should look like
it can either be an infographic type or
it can be a decisional tree that will
help the user to figure out which
standard is relevant for their work and
for their lab environment
now some standards exist and we can do
the mapping of all of them but others
need to be created where there are gaps
and this can be done in two ways
one way is from bottom up
this
for example coming from the research
need of the organization to have some
communication or process or data
standards to fit the purpose or it can
be developed from top down which means
from the compliance from the regulatory
side
and as an example of an industry-wise
initiative developed by the
alliance and its members we have the
health notation which is the
hierarchical editing language for
macromolecules
which is a system of standardized naming
for complex biomolecules
it's widely adopted it's used for
representing therapeutic large molecule
in the bioregistration systems
and helm is now an fda recognized
submission format which also received an
award of the best practice from the
bioid world
here is another example of initiative
that can help standardize the data
across the industry this is called the
idmp ontology project the idmp comes
from identification of medicinal
products and the terminology is being
used in different domains as you can see
on the columns that are marked in blue
in the development in the production in
regulation authorization and so on
the project is aiming at creating the
ontology that will line top down the
idmp iso standards to the in-house
standards of the organizations to reduce
the current implementation
inconsistencies at the organization
level and in this way it can save time
and costs
on the right side you can see another
example of a regulatory initiative which
is called in vitro pharmacology project
where the fda
invited the pistol alliance to help
develop the data standards for in vitro
pharmacology bio assay
the project just started and the aim is
to accelerate the submission process
by defining the ontologies that will
enable better data reuse interpretation
and understanding
and all these examples and top-down
standards that are being developed will
be seen at the laboratory level in a
period of time but from a process
perspective these top-down standards are
very efficient because because they
created the need of everybody to accept
the same ontologies and data standards
now the pistol alliance
has
also other communities of interest that
are connected to the lab of the future
and we create also collaborations and
partnership between these communities
on the left side you can see the data
governance community this is managed by
my colleague john rice
in the middle you see the aiml community
of interest
this is managed by my colleague vladimir
makarov and on the right side you see an
ad another example of community which is
the uix community managed by my
colleague paola de matas
so if we take one by one with the data
guy finance community we created the
series of standards webinars data
governance is essential to enable
digital transformation and to advance
innovation and this growing community
already has more than 30 companies that
bring together
opinion leaders to identify best
practices common obstacles and some
potential solutions that we can all work
together
the ai community of interest is aiming
at discovering and promoting the best
ways to use these
new promising technologies
to apply them to solve the current
challenges and to educate
the companies through presentations and
discussions
and when implementing tools and software
ai ml an important aspect is to consider
the change management and particularly
the user adoption
so the dedicated user experience
community which is formed by
practitioners from the pharmaceutical
health care and software industries
is delivering frameworks and guides and
toolkits to enable the businesses to
adopt
ux principles and methods and their most
recent initiative is to create concepts
and ideas that will help the lab of the
future community
last few years we saw rapid growth in
terms of the number of new
pre-competitive collaborations between
the pharma companies and ai providers
and software providers
and in general the uh the organizations
from the r d equal system
and in 2022 digital transformation
continues to accelerate
and the pharmaceutical industry is
seeing the benefits of non-competitive
collaborations and at the beginning
when the companies are learning how to
assess their organization and the
potential for digital transformations
we do encourage them to join different
non-competitive platforms and groups to
learn from the experience of the other
companies and same for the organizations
that are
the digital journey because it's useful
to contribute into and to help each
other by sharing the use cases and best
practices and lessons learned and in
this way the organizations together can
share both the risks and the benefits of
the deliverables
now if you are not part of an
organization yet
if you are a student or an early
graduate i do encourage you to join the
communities of interest
most of the discussions are open you can
join without any registration cost and
you can be more in contact with what is
happening in the in the industry
i would say a recommendation to
stay informed to subscribe to different
newsletters about your area of interest
to join different webinars and
discussions
and very important to be proactive uh so
for example if you see a challenge uh
discuss it with others maybe look for
some solutions and if you see a
challenge and a solution
you can join different working groups um
you can reach out to different
not-for-profit organizations that have
the means and the contacts uh to
validate the concept and to bring the
right stakeholders at the table
i want to show you how at the pistoia
alliance we create new projects we are
constantly developing uh new projects uh
and the process starts with the ideation
phase
uh where the pre-competitive project
idea is being raised the idea can come
from anybody
then the idea is being validated with
the community in terms of the benefits
and the interest
and once there is a buy-in for that
particular idea
it then starts to take a shape into a
project that has a clear problem
statement and the industry benefit
the outcome can be a member-funded
project or a program it can be a new
formed community of experts
and
this is the exact same path
that
we went on for creating the woman in
stem pilot program that i'm about to
present you
so firstly why is the women in stem
topic important for so many
organizations
you might not see
gender imbalance at the university or in
your early career levels
but the gender imbalance in the top
executive roles is a well-documented
case unfortunately so student so studies
showed
that women are more likely to leave the
stem career pipeline than men
leading to a wider gap
at the senior level
so women account for only three percent
of the ceos in this field and this is
why the pistol alliance has chosen to
focus this pilot's scheme on the
leadership roles because we believe that
um we believe in the top-down
changes and in creating more role models
for the future generations
and this was the process
we started in april last year at the
pistol alliance conference where we had
the women in stem panel with some very
interesting discussions that continued
even after the end of the conference
and by the way some of the most
interesting discussions happened before
and after the presentations so if you're
a student or an early graduate at the
conference
don't limit uh to
to the presentations to listening to the
presentations try to network and join
the conversations that happen during the
breaks
or in the organized networking events
and the poster sessions and and so on
you can get a lot of valuable
information from there
and connect with the right people
so um
going back to
how we started this program uh in april
last year we received the feedback from
the participants that really made us
think um
of the different programs that we can
initiate to help the woman who the women
who want to start uh or grow into their
stem career
so in quarter three we gathered more
interested parties and we asked the
participants what do they think are the
biggest barriers for women in stem
and the lack of child care maternity
policies
depending on
also the locations but also the absence
of female role models were mentioned as
the barriers
but by far the greatest thing to be the
workplace culture
and we didn't go into more depth at that
time
but we knew that the workplace culture
is highly influenced by the leadership
and the strategic organizational
directions and the management
so what was also interesting
in q3 was the feedback that came from
one of the only two men
who joined the court uh he experienced
for the first time the feeling of being
in the minority
uh and this feedback confirmed that in
the women in stem program all genders
need to be involved we agreed that any
diversity effort needs to incorporate
the intersectionality
which is the acknowledgement that
everyone has their own unique experience
when it comes to discrimination and that
gender can make people feel marginalized
and that is why we wanted to make sure
that everybody is well represented and
that men are included in all aspects of
the program
in q4 we started the different
ideas on how the program should look
like and the most appealing
idea to our members
was the one to create a cross-company
training and networking program which is
what we are piloting now with top
managers from the pharma companies
uh the current pilot program uh brings
together 40 participants from 12
countries from three continents for a
period of six months
we started in january we will finish in
june this year we currently have 17
companies involved in this pilot stage
and each group of 10 participants
includes
two men as minority
uh the group meetings are held weekly we
have accredited trainer and coach and we
also have monthly networking sessions
uh each group includes diversity in
terms of the gender race location role
function
almost half of the participants are from
the us the other half is mostly from
europe and china and the prestai
alliance brought together
leaders with different areas of
expertise because we wanted to see
different perspectives
and these are limited but not included
are including but not limited to the
drugs research development data science
industry regulation drug safety and so
on
and just to tell you that these women in
stem pilot program it's a first step in
a wider diversity and inclusion in stem
leadership initiative
and we are aiming to run a series of
future programs as of september this
year
uh using the feedback and the learnings
from this pilot program um
we would like to form a community of
leaders who share the same values and
that want to contribute to the change in
the overall industry either by directly
changing or by promoting uh quality in
their organizations
if you want to find out more about
the pistol alliance and how you can get
engaged please do reach out to us on the
website and again for students and early
graduates uh join the industry
discussions uh stay informed ask
questions and be proactive
reach out to us
thank you very much
thank you so much and for such a
wonderful presentation i have a question
how do competing big pharma companies
collaborate in the pistol alliance
projects
well we facilitate a non-competitive
environment so for example we bring
together uh
projects or ideas or solutions that if
the companies are working together
there's a benefit for the whole industry
there is no competitive advantage right
so that's why we can bring different
companies that even if for example in
the in the day-to-day business
environment they are in competition
we bring them together with projects and
initiatives that all of them can benefit
because imagine that if for example a
company has a big challenge
uh one thing is to try to solve the
challenge by its own
which means investing resources and
resources can be hiring a lot of people
to try to solve that issue uh
spending the money the time and so on or
they can share the risk right and the
resources with other companies that are
facing similar challenges and try to
solve them uh together
okay we got it
yeah thank you for answering the
question and the next question is uh
what is the challenge that big pharma is
trying to solve with bioinformatics
well i think it's also related with the
with the data standards and and actually
when it comes to challenges from the
industry we always ask the participants
and um
we want to understand what is the
challenge and what we can do for that
challenge right
thank you and do we have any more
questions
okay we have one more question what are
some of the challenges faced in the
current role as a strategic theme lead
and how do you handle those challenges
well the challenges that i see are
mostly related with uh ensuring that we
have all the right stakeholders at the
table so for example
if somebody comes to me with an idea or
a challenge and says look i need more
people that
would be willing to work
together on solving this issue right for
me one of the challenges is okay uh i do
have a lot of contacts who is the best
person to come and work on this
particular project all validating that a
challenge that one company is facing
it's actually a challenge that more
companies are facing because many times
it happens that the company comes with a
challenge
that is not very sure if other companies
are facing similar one so then this this
comes the validation process that i'm
doing going and talking with different
companies seeing if that challenge is
similar and if we have an idea on a
solution that we can work
together to solve it
okay
okay
and uh our last question
uh mohammed is asking how can we join
women in stem program
so currently the women in stem is for
the
people that are in the top executive
roles in the pharma because the way we
started this program we saw that at the
entry level so it depends on where you
are right if if you are at the entry
level in a career there are
similar programs for entry level right
um what we saw we saw the need of doing
the same in the top executive to make
sure that the people that join at the
entry level
can have the
same chances for advancing the career
right so uh our program is targeted at
leadership roles and you can join by by
uh going on the website of the pistol
alliance and you will see there under
the project the program and you can
register either to join either to be
informed or with the newsletter
information
okay perfect i hope maham you have your
answer and you can join yeah thank you
so much